so we're in Berlin and we found what may
or may not be the Berlin Wall it is a
wall in Berlin whether it's the Berlin
Wall
we're not entirely we hope to find
someone we can ask that but nevertheless
it's a nice big wall in Berlin and so as
I keep saying walls are awesome because
when you have a wall all of a sudden you
it becomes really clear your planes so
if I stand beside this wall and I start
like reaching around I see where I lose
my planes now some of you have already
realized that if I take my place a
forward split time and I just reach my
hands back for a lot of you the planes
go crazy and that's normal that's just
what happens at first and you won't fix
it in one week you cannot in one week do
this if you apply there isn't that I've
never seen that happen it takes a long
time to you know there's so many people
there's so many people making pictures
of this wall I think it's the Berlin
Wall so yeah so it's gonna take weeks
and months to master your plants so sure
you reach back and they go come on come
on come on just take one boy and just
gently start to play with it you know
you'll you'll with time figure out how
to move your hand but it's really gonna
take time to develop all the the muscle
memory in the motor skills so yeah don't
stress just play with it a few minutes
at a time you know and it'll it'll as
long as you notice and put a little bit
of time into it it'll start to work and
then next ring you'll be able to go
through a full circle it's like doing
yogurt strength training
yeah the bench press twice your body
weight in one week no matter what you do
it's just it will take time so same
thing that planes the walls will help
having some strategies help so then it
just takes time in practice so I hope
you find you know in your neighborhood a
nice historic wall that once divided
cognitive communism and democracy
because all better that way